ready for this first step well plenty of
folks are happy to see the holidays wind
down most people wish the holiday season
lasted longer than it actually does 52
percent say they may try to fit in as
many festive activities as possible but
the same percentage agree there is not
enough time in the holiday season to do
everything they want to do do you wish
the holidays lasted longer no and thank
you for not acknowledging that I look
like a mole Santa who got fired for
smoking pot with the elves that was nice
of you um here it is really quick okay
okay people are trying to do too much
and that's why they think the season is
too short everybody needs to stop trying
to have the coolest Christmas on
Instagram and just Pace themselves
listen to some music have a good time
growing up in my house there were five
Christmas activities okay you got the
tree you went the mass you went to
Christmas Eve you went to Christmas day
you went to rehab you were done ho ho ho
I'll see you at the gym New Year's day
everybody needs to chill out get off
Instagram you don't need to broadcast
every second of your holiday oh Timmy
made a snowman nobody cares don't assume
the snowman's gender anyway move on with
your life sorry
to be so nice
fasting Our Lives though that's I don't
doubt that Timmy's a fine snowman
connoisseur but I feel like we're
everyone's running their own one-man
news service during the holiday season
and it's exhausting everybody you know
makes Christmas cards Jenny makes a
fabulous Christmas card but it's a big
production you know because you got to
pick the photos we put this one here do
we put that one there are you a photo
Jenny is a heavyweight like a Hollywood
heavyweight like she brings in James
Cameron there's special effects involved
CGI it's a lot judge you look we all
love the holidays don't get us wrong but
do you wish they lasted longer you know
why people wish they last longer because
they don't get started until the week
before Christmas and then they're like
oh my gosh I didn't get everything done
so I wish it lasted longer if they would
get started the day after Thanksgiving
get everything done then they'd be done
by you know December 25th so I don't
wish they lasted longer I'd rather hang
myself at this point I mean I'm so tired
of Christmas decorations in my house get
those grandkiddies though I got one oh
one Geraldo what about you living in
Ohio the
the end of the holiday season is very
very traumatic because there's nothing
ahead of you there's January and maybe
have Martin Luther King weekend and then
February and by March you want to kill
yourself I mean it really is so so Grim
the weather is so bad so cold so gray
you wish the holiday season lasted at
least until March and the Browns are not
making it don't say that don't say that
it could be let me tell you something
the Browns have a great shot on Xbox
okay they got a really good shot there's
a PlayStation involved the Browns could
go all the way you have young kids so do
you wish it lasted longer no because you
can keep the Santa threat going the
second I unwrap the last present for
myself I'm immediately depressed and
then it becomes you have to clean up
everything you have to clean up the
table the wrapping paper and if you
don't clean up the wrapping paper during
the unwrapping process that's not how
you do things so yes there's something
very very dark and scary it's a dark
winter once that last president so do
you live in that house winter is coming
do you live in that house where every
Christmas morning photo has a hefty bag
in the background yes
in fact one kid as soon as I finish
opening one has to wait until the
garbage goes in the back and that nobody
touches anything until that stops and
I'm not even enjoying the unwrapping I'm
just trying to clean up the whole time I
sort of feel that Christmas has to kind
of last through until February because
all the people that you wanted to get
together with it can't all work out in
one month so you end up pushing it into
the new year and you're still saying
Merry Christmas and happy New Year on
President's Day as a so to speak in
Latin families though it is prolonged in
the sense that uh three kings did on
January 6th is really the time when kids
get their gifts often particularly in
Catholic Latino never heard of that
before I know yeah three kids
religion as well January 6th has a
religious meaning yes January 6th has a
religious
maybe that's what they're doing at the
Capitol they were partying oh yeah up
the next several States picking a
surprising favorite Christmas movie in a
new study I've never heard of this one
Edward Scissorhands topping the list in
Arizona California Florida and New
Mexico the movie does not even take
place during the holidays but some fans
pointing pointing to this iconic snow
scene you might remember
[Music]
and then there's Die Hard which does
take place during Christmas taught the
list in Idaho and Montana what do you
think Edward Scissorhands is that a
Christmas movie you wonder why people
consider them Christmas movies because
they always air on Christmas people
watch reruns on Christmas it's not a new
release day I mean The Ultimate
Christmas movie I think is Christmas
Story which would never get made today
with the bullying and the BB gun they'd
be like nah we'll take cocaine bear
instead it's less offensive uh but I
always grew up in A Christmas Story
house uh there was always some It's a
Wonderful Life in Cleveland I was on
Long Island I was a little bit of It's a
Wonderful Life the only Christmas movie
I don't lean into is Love Actually we've
talked about this a lot on the show yeah
the best experience I had watching Love
Actually was in 2010 I was a cab driver
Jenny wanted to watch it Christmas night
one-year-old Lincoln walked out of his
bedroom 20 minutes in threw up on
himself and that ended the movie because
Jenny had to go clean them up they never
saw how it ended I've seen how it ended
5 000 times okay I might I might have
got the kids sick on purpose but I'm not
going to confess just in case do you
watch movies on Christmas no and I've
never seen It's a Wonderful Life
the story never watch the whole thing
dude our Christmas movie is home alone
yeah
parents would get a red for negligence
at the end of the movie
I would say ELP is the the best of the
modern movies but Miracle on 34th Street
and it's a wonderful life you have to
watch this I mean this is part of your
education
we grew up in the era where Miracle on
34th Street was the next winning a
playoff game
yeah that would be a miracle was that
1973. I love die hard you know I'm the
shoot him up kind of up the kind of kind
of guy
die hard is my favorite I can watch that
over and over but you know I saw a
miracle on 35 I've never seen like you
never seen Edward Scissorhands I don't
know I saw Edward Scissorhands I just
didn't think it was a Christmas movie oh
well I've never seen it am I the only
one I've ever seen it I think you'd like
it what does he do with his scissor
handle besides cut hair it Hedges it's
kind of like a feel-good Freddy Krueger
available to hire I mean it's been about
20 years since I saw it so I'll have to
refresh my memory all right up next when
do you take down the tree Acton Justin
Hartley admits he keeps his up for many
many months the This Is Us star telling
people magazine this my whole thing is
if you come over to my house in July
there might be a Christmas tree up I
don't mind putting them up but taking
them down is a nightmare it's sad and
it's such a pain so I just keep it lit
up through January and then Into Summer
but if you do the same get ready for a
backlash on your lock nearly half of
Americans say decorations should be
packed away before the end of January
this summer we moved into a new
apartment building and I was out in the
courtyard one day doing a conference
call and I looked I was looking up at
the balconies and there was somebody
that had their Christmas tree out on
their balcony this is July and I was
like what is that and I took a picture
because Kennedy lives in the same
building I was like oh like is this you
but judge you have a beautiful home and
you've decorated it so nicely do you
leave it up for a while you know what I
used to leave it up until January 6
because that's the Feast of the Epiphany
and that you know it's a religious thing
um and I'm a Roman Catholic but I have a
lot of family Greek orthodists uh but
now like I'm getting a little crazy like
I want it down I want my house back you
know clean it up it's enough already but
the tree is uh you know you've got to
get rid of it because it starts shedding
it's different than Christmas lights
Christmas lights really add to the
character of the neighborhood and they
really are very warm and I like them I
mean I I guess past January is really I
mean the end of gender is really pushing
it yeah but they're lovely and I like
them
what about you so then you leave them up
for a while I well I don't usually hang
them because I have a Jewish wife and if
I did I would have to sleep outside
okay and what about you I know you clean
up all the presents right away what
about the tree yeah it comes down within
a day or two yeah oh yeah and people are
actually lazy and that's why they don't
take their tree down but they're saying
it's because they're in the spirit of
Christmas that's not true they're just
lazy
Justin's lazy how about lights yeah
lights yeah those come down pretty soon
too colored lights are white lights I'm
a white light guy but I don't judge
colors my answer I have friends the
whitlocks they don't keep their tree up
for long after Christmas because there's
like they have a birthday in their
family so but they put their tree up
November one
do they do they live in a CVS what are
you talking about they love Christmas
they just do it early this is the
problem everybody's doing wrong with
Christmas they're starting too early
like a drugstore they put the day after
Halloween the day after Thanksgiving my
aunt friend was most efficient Christmas
Easter I've ever met day after
Thanksgiving the tree went up she hosted
Christmas day but the tree was in a box
by the time you went home on Christmas
night and again as a kid you're like
whoa whoa and friend let's breathe but
as an adult you're like Fran I get it
you need help with this box yeah you
help her out a little bit all right one
more up next ever wonder when to tell
your family or friends sleeping over at
your house during the holidays that it's
time to go well most people say guests
officially overstay they're welcome
after four days four days definitely
maybe three what about you yo four hours
four hours
from my side of the family we only have
the we don't have anybody out of town so
they're only there for one day I hosted
Thanksgiving it started at three o'clock
at nine o'clock football's over at nine
o'clock people were at my house I almost
went to the neighbors and called the
cops on myself I was like what are you
guys doing here six uh four hours at a
one day event if you're on the road okay
because I do go to Ohio with Jenny's
family it's like two days you wanna know
why because there's nothing to do by day
three that's when the bad eating and the
Bad drinking starts it's not the
holidays that get you fat it's the days
you treat like holidays
thank you you have guests coming over no
my grandparents used to come over to the
house and we would wake up the next
morning and they'd be gone one they
would be out the door at six a.m and we
appreciated that yeah Ben Franklin said
fish and visitors think after three days
I think that that's probably true you
were there when he said it
I remember it well I sat on it does you
have a rule uh no no I love when my
sister comes and when my mom she would
never stay long enough I just I just
love him yeah I could have my my mom and
my sister stay for a long time yeah yeah
the rest of you anyone else
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else